hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the chest comms
computer Chess Championship it's a rapid
game played between Lee Lash's zero in
the shredder 13 that sounds kind of nice
kind of like Android 13 but you know
that plays chess it's it's I'm sure
you'll agree okay the title of the video
might be a bit over reaching it but
you'll see what I mean by it it's it's
very impressive and I'm sure there's
like a very reasonable explanation
someone who's into self-learning
AIS might be able to explain it but I
will talk about it a bit more after we
get to that part and I didn't do any
videos yesterday I was really busy now
we were picking grapes you know because
all that wine is not going to make
itself and we don't have a couple of
nice photos from the grape picking event
there you have that's me with with my
father and some friends in the back so I
do hope you enjoyed that and also here
is a photo of everyone who participated
in this event it's very hard to take a
photo of everyone and not not blinking
but you know most of the people are are
facing forward and it's a very nice
photo of friends and family so I hope
you enjoyed that as well now let's check
out this very nice game Lila has the
white pieces and she opens with d4 we
have d5 c4 e6 nice to f3 and Knight to
f6 so the Queens gambit declined is on
the board Knight to c3 and now D
captures on c4 we have E 4 and now
Bishop to b4 simply pinning the knight
developing the bishop
a very nice move Bishop to g5 by Leela
very principled decision you know
putting your piece as far into your
opponent's camp as possible
we have c5 attacking White's strong
center and now Bishop captures on c4 c
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 and
the bishop captures on c3 be captures on
c3 and here Queen to a5 attacking the
isolated c3 pawn and white plays Bishop
to b5 check a very nice move and black
has a couple of couple
options of dealing with this Bishop to
b5 check for example you could play
night after D 7 which is sometimes this
is actually a good response in in Bishop
to b5 check like there are variations
over the benoni where you can go night
the night you that was already developed
to d7 instead of developing the other
night but here it's just not so great
you could also block with this night for
example night bt7
and allow something like Bishop captures
Queen captures and c3 check King f1 and
captures on f6 and although you would
get a semi-open G file perhaps you could
use this to attack the white king but
white actually has a lot of development
here and black black King also isn't
feeling very safe in the center
so instead Bishop to d7 developing a
peace offering an exchange so black can
further develop Bishop captures on f6
first and here we have G captures on f6
that was played in the game Queen
captures on c3 would check also possible
but not not really favorable for black
for example King to f1 check and now
after captures you get Knight captures
and now the Queen isn't positioned so
well on c3 the knight is attacking the
Queen the queen is already threatening
checkmate on d8 and there's really no
good way to deal with this you have to
capture the bishop and allow Knight the
c7 check and you have to lose the D
exchange here if you if you don't
there's there's really nothing to to
play here you can go out Queen CH to
prevent both threats because then you
get a nice to d6 and you lose the Queen
due to due to the fork so you have to
allow captures captures check King your
fate and now you will be simply winning
this game is white so after Bishop
captures on f6 we have G captures on f6
leaving the c3 pawn as it is and now
Bishop captures on d7 now I've got 477
and here lela simply castles so what's
the idea can you grab the pawn here our
that's really you don't want to allow
Knight the 5 and here of course the
Queen now has to stand the C file or
night c7 is still an idea Knight the to
d6 check is most likely White's next
move so not really after castles we have
Queen to e5
a very nice centralizing move
by the black queen what it's White's the
place so what do you do here look the b1
simply developing the rook also this
comes with a nice attack against the b7
pawn and here you have to ask yourself
can I capture the e4 pawn and also while
I capture the d4 pawn I'm gonna be
protecting the b7 pawn it's not really
possible if Queen captures then you get
the rook to e1 the queen is under attack
you move the Queen
you get rook to b5 Oh white already has
so much activity for this one point
let's say Knights the c5 you block you
get c4 Queen moves and now comes this
very unpleasant Knight capture some d6
opening up a discovered attack towards
the black Queen Queen captures and now
Knight to c7 first king moves now rook
captures Queen with check King captures
and now rook captures and c5 would check
King to b6 and now Rock to a5 and the
blacks doubled F pawn will be really a
liability because you will lose the f6
pawn this will come with a check and
then white is already up upon and blacks
rooks are still to be developed so white
would very much enjoy this position so
after loop to be one night the c5 a very
nice move brings in another attacker
against d4 pawn also the night now
guards the b7 pawn and it's a very nice
square for for the Black Knight because
as you can see white has no beep on and
white has no deep on so you can't use
any points to dislodge the night from c5
look the before this is really a
beautiful move by Leela what's the idea
behind it well you still can't capture
the e4 pawn not really if you play
Knight captures then you get it's
actually a very nice idea but you can
feel free feel free to pause the video
here and find why you can't play Knight
captures on e4 just you know punish
black in this position I'll give you a
couple of seconds first to the side as
usual for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent Punisher of bad moves and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy show
Queen to a4 check simply brings this
craze this nice battery here against the
knight on e4 and I've
black moves you get a nightcap cause any
sex this night captures any sex is
pretty much the idea in all of these
variations f captures and now simply
wrote characters on e4 Queen moves and
now Queen checks King more screen
capture some b7 King cups to g6 and now
you have a position where you have a
king than g6 that's pretty much
self-explanatory so after rook to be for
Knight captures doesn't work the screen
captures work not really then you get
Knight captures and e6 immediately and
now of course you cannot capture with
the Queen because her rook to e1 would
win your queen and your queen is already
under attack so you have to move the
Queen let's say Queen to c6 and now you
get Knight captures on c5 Queen captures
rook to e1 check King to f8 and Queen to
d7 already there are so many threats
here this rook can either capture and
cause problem series can come to g4 and
then it would completely control the G
and the e-file it's a too much to handle
for black
so after this rook to b4 which is a very
nice move we have castles in my shredder
rook to e1 developing the rook and now
look F to d8 black also wants to develop
the rooks rook to e3 a nice rock lifts
you do have to bring it into the attack
at some point and now comes Rock a to c8
also now introducing another attacker
against the weak c3 pawn but white
already played a move to to defend it
and also all of black's pieces are now
developed we have Queen to g4 check
Queen to g5 walking and Leela decides
not to trade Queens just yet Queen to e2
and now comes King to a trade black
could perhaps use the semi open G file
for attack now as you know pretty much
the dusts seems to have settled g3 you
know a print preemptive strike against
rook to g8
we have E 5 now kicking away this
powerful Knight and now comes h4 and I
situations a bit before reacting to this
threat Queen to g6 and now comes Knight
to f5 black does have an excellent
square for the knight on c5 but why to
now has an excellent square for the
knight also on f5
here we have rook to c7 guarding the b7
pawn and now comes Luke to c4 so now the
knight can't really move as the rope
would be hanging on c7 black plays b6
defending the knight now the rook can
move perhaps rook to d7 is an idea black
might want to double rooks on the D file
and here we have the critical moment of
the game here really pause the video and
try to figure out what you would play
here with the white pieces as it's very
essential to this video ends to the to
the whole title of the video and
everything so you know there is no
killer move here or anything but you
know just try to figure out what you
would play here
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you really have have a
nice imagination and for those who just
want to enjoy it so here you could play
something like King to g2 for example
improve the position of the king and and
see what black will play and then so on
and then so on but Alleva actually
played rook captures on c5 and this is
this is a very how would I say it it
really shows imagination because what
you want what you want to do is
definitely of course you see that the
queen is guarding h5 so at some point
you do want to push h5 and h6 but if
this pawn comes to h6 then perhaps I
don't know you will weaken the g5 Square
perhaps this Knight can then come at
some point to e6 the g5 and from there
it will be actually a great attacking
piece against white so what Lilith did
here she saw that after rook captures
what was played in the game and rook
captures and now we have to ask
yourselves where is the compensation
here why is this exchange sacrifice so
good it's so good because blacks rooks
are not very useful here first
h5 now you see the idea queen comes to
g8 and now comes roof to d3 so not only
did leave a sacrifice the exchange but
she also wants to get rid of the other
the other pair of rooks
because this Knight an f5 will be
nothing but nothing on the board will be
able to challenge it it's simply a
monstrosity and it's I mean it's it's
much better than a rook
so queen - a fate awaiting move just you
know hoping white will capture and then
black might control the D file first h6
Oliva simply improves the position so
now you see this idea of having a
beautiful night on f5 and this pawn on
h6 is now much stronger without there
actually being a dark knight on the
board Roxy to c8 we have looked a d5 now
and here also perhaps a nice critical
moment in the game for both white and
black because here of course it seems
like black can capture the c3 pawn but
then the position doesn't seem very
favorable for black for example Queen to
g4 whatever black plays let's say look
to see it there really isn't much to do
here Queen h4 you can threaten the f6
pawn here and it's pretty much not I
don't know it's not a great position for
black of course you will never capture
on d5 if you capture on d5 then you
simply give white a nice pass pawn which
will be supported by the night from f5
so here let's say look to c6 guarding
the pawn and to me it's not clear how
white or black would make progress here
but pretty sure Lila would find a way as
shredder decided not to capture the c3
pawn but pretty much black doesn't
really have a useful move here you can
never really do anything with the Queen
ideas like Queen g4 fall by Queen g7
will be an idea you constantly have to
keep an eye on the weak f6 pawn so it's
simply a much better position for white
regardless of white being down material
but a shredder trusts Leela and decides
not to capture the c3 pawn rather he
plays rook captures on d5 and now when
you see a captures on d5 and now you see
that this this pawn now became a
passport and it it can at some point be
even a protected passed pawn so what do
you do here again rook captures on c3
shredder decides not to capture this
pawn for some reason probably probably
thinking it's it's not going to be
anything to do with the game I really
don't know
and instead goes rook to a3 I might
forgot I might have forgotten to mention
this lily is still rated around 3300 and
shredder I believe is somewhere around
3100 so it's definitely all of the moves
are her great moves but for some reason
decides not to capture the c3 pawn and
okay Queen to a3 we have Queen to h5 now
attacking the f7 pawn and here we have
Luke to f8 so now the rook is stuck here
guarding the position and black managed
to activate the Queen moves like Queen
g4 are not not very useful the rook can
always block this with rook to g8 so we
have Queen to f3 guarding the c3 pawn
queen to c1 check King moves to g2 and
now comes Queen to g5 so this was blacks
idea put the rook in the back to keep an
eye on this f7 pawn and on the back rank
and we know via this maneuver Queen 2 a
3 2 c1 2 g5 black managed to take
advantage of white weakening the g5
square so very nice but here comes c4
and now Leela has a protected the D pawn
a protected passed pawn and now this is
definitely a game changer we have roped
the d8 now trying to develop to bring
the other look into the game as well and
now comes d6 the knight is very much
very much alive here and guarding the
pass pawn so now we have a past deep on
you have a beautiful pond on h6 a
defended night on f5 and I'm sure
everyone will agree that this is not a
much stronger piece than this rook on d8
Queen to g6 black can only wait and see
what happens we have a for Queen to g5
and now comes a 5 trying to create
another weakness on the Queen side it's
often a principle that one weakness is
not enough to win the game you often
have to create a second weakness and
then black will be overwhelmed Queen to
g6 black of course it doesn't want a
capture on a5 even though it wins
material but then white gets a second
pass pawn queen to e4
we have Queen back to g5 black and
simply wait to see what happens and now
Queen to be won and now you have this
beautiful position where there's really
not all that much to do for black we
have rook to b8 now defending the b6
pawn but now comes c5 and now you can't
even capture this soon-to-be another
passport because it's pinned the rockin
b8 is undefended and look at the harmony
between White's pieces and pawns and the
Queen from b1 is is a it's simply a
monster controlling the the B file you
can't capture because the Queen would
capture the rook the queen is also
guarding the knight on f5 that guards
the d6 pawn okay now the d6 pawn is also
guarded by the c5 pawn but the night
also guards the h6 pawn so everything is
perfect in White's camp this is
something not off often seen b5 now
black has a passed pawn of its own but
simply not enough because here comes c6
now when you see two connected passed
pawns on the sixth rank you know that
the game is over Queen to d2 was played
that now comes Queen e4 we have rook to
a fate black can only wait and see what
happens c7 we have Queen to d1 and now
comes Queen to c6 preparing to push the
other pawn and the queen is on a nice
light square diagonal so no checks can
be given here efore simply trying
something of course now Queen to f3
wouldn't be very favorable for white so
first Queen captures on e4 rope to g8
and now comes a queen to d4 now we have
Queen captures Knight captures and now
f5 black is just making nonsense moves
and you know probably they are trained
not to resign d7 we have f4 simply bring
your Queen into the game even f3 is
played here Knight captures now comes f6
Queen captures on f6 with Czech rook has
the block only move and now comes Queen
captures on g7 and we have a nice
checkmate against the shredder 13 rated
somewhere around 3100 so a beautiful
game and I really do hope you enjoyed it
and that the title wasn't too much but
really when you look at the
position and if you pause the video then
I'm sure all of you had your doubts but
here after this b6 move was played you
really have to see that the knight on f5
is simply a monster night that this pawn
does have a huge potential of coming
here and probably the reasoning behind
this move is that any other move doesn't
allow Lila to play for the win and by
playing rook captures and not pawn
captures of course you don't want to do
that and rook captures you're not worse
you have a you have a monster night I
mean the the potential of the position
is is huge here and perhaps that's why
that's why Lila did it but I'm sure some
of my viewers are familiar with you know
self-learning AI techniques of making
decision so maybe you can shed some
light on this situation so I do hope you
enjoyed the game and especially this
rook captures on c5 move I thought it
was really really spectacular and
regarding the Haggadah matter quest
congratulations to all of you who were
able to complete it here is a short
overview of my Twitter feed I searched
for the hashtag and MOT requests so
there you can see how many of you were
actually able to complete it and the
list is like really really huge those of
you who have completed it like really
quickly I tried to you know congratulate
everyone and to retweet your tweets and
everything but really so many of you
have managed to complete the Argonaut
request so I was very impressed by that
and the list keeps loading simply so
many of you have managed to complete the
quest so I don't know
perhaps the quest was too easy for you
so now I hope you're ready for the
second quest and as usual well not as
usual because this is only the second
quest you you will be given but you know
the the guide to the quest will be in
the description below and it's basically
the same thing only this time you have
to win I like to serve licorice without
wasting without wasting any pieces so
you can waste pawns
but you cannot waste any pieces so all
the pieces have to stay on the board
use the same technique hashtag target
matter quest and you will see we'll see
how you do with this one and you know
you can try completing the quest without
using the Skol scholar made technique in
in bullet games because you know
eventually you will complete the quest
by doing that so that's the game I would
like to thank slug at cansada Daniel to
boot
Kevin Vishnevsky and micro G Raimondi
and miroslav jankovic for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos you're thinking
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon and good luck with the quest